on february 14 2019 a suicide bomber
attacked a convoy of indian security
forces
they're getting reports of multiple
casualties in a row killed at least 40
indian soldiers here in kashmir
the deadliest attack the region has seen
this century
the bomber was part of an islamic
militant group based in pakistan
jaish muhammad claimed responsibility
for that
attack 12 days later india carried out
airstrikes in northwestern pakistan
then pakistan shot down at least one
indian aircraft around here
tensions rose between the two rival
nations it can escalate
to escalate serious escalation in years
kashmir is one of the most disputed
places on earth over the course of 70
years
it's been at the center of three wars
fought between
two massive armies it's heavily occupied
by more than half a million indian
troops
and a deadly collection of militias and
terrorist groups kashmir is the stage
for the relentless conflict between
india and pakistan but focusing on these
two countries can obscure what's really
at stake
the voice of kashmiris who are caught in
a vicious cycle of violence
whenever there is any conflict between
india and pakistan kashmir
is always the battleground kashmir is a
disputed area it neither belongs to
india nor belongs to pakistan
two giants of nuclear giants we are
nothing in between them
there is always uncertainty you know you
never know what is going to happen
it can be a har tal it can be a strike
it can no anybody can be killed anytime
we are the pawns in their hands it's a
mess it is a mess and we have been
affected
in every possible direct and indirect
way i have been born
in this conflict and i have to die
within this
conflict kashmir is one of the most
strategic places in the world
where three powerful countries collide
india
pakistan and china china invaded and
took this slice of kashmir from india
and was given this one by pakistan
india and pakistan control these parts
but lay claim to more
this region is at the center of a brutal
conflict over these disputed borders
so it's important to start when the
borders were being drawn
in the mid-1800s india was a patchwork
of several hundred provinces
and princely states under british rule a
century later when british india won
independence
the british left and hastily decided to
split the region into two
these areas would be a new
muslim-majority country pakistan
and this would be the mostly hindu but
secular india
the partition was bloody communal hatred
flares
up in the punjab one million people
become refugees overnight
they flee from savagery and butchery
that has never been exceeded even in
india's stormy history
amid the chaos some princely states were
given the choice to join either country
in most cases the ruling monarchs
followed the will of their people
but this state called jammu and kashmir
was different
it was right along this new border and
had a muslim-majority population but was
ruled by a hindu monarch
when asked to pick a side the ruler
chose to stay neutral
fearing that the monarch would join
india the kashmiri population rebelled
here in 1947.
armed tribesmen from pakistan soon
joined the fight
the monarch turned to india for military
help and an exchange agreed to join them
which sparked the first indo-pakistan
war in kashmir
[Music]
continuing thus increase the threat to
world peace
and brought the dispute to the attention
of the united nations
the u.n security council brokered a
ceasefire in 1949
which established this line with
pakistan controlling this side
and india this one it also asked
pakistani tribesmen to withdraw
and indian troops to follow so that
kashmir could hold a direct vote to
decide its own future
but neither held up their end of the
deal pakistan argued that kashmir's
muslim-majority population
rightfully belonged with them while
india insisted that kashmir was handed
over to them by the hindu monarch
so they doubled down and added kashmir
to their constitution
the vote was never held i think every
person
in kashmir has been affected by india
and pakistan the kashmir is completely
destroyed
by india as well as by pakistan this is
a territorial dispute they call it they
don't need people
the main stakeholders are the kashmiris
their opinions are not being heard
both countries continue to tighten their
grip around it for decades
kashmir fighting is going on and heavy
casualties in men and equipment
have been inflicted on the aggressor in
1965
the second indo-pakistan war broke out
in kashmir thousands of people were
killed between the huge armies on both
sides
a ceasefire ended the war but didn't
change this line
kashmir was kept divided and occupied
another war broke out in 1971 this time
the focus wasn't in kashmir
it was in east pakistan here india
helped rebels fight for independence
and dealt pakistan a devastating defeat
this region became a new country
bangladesh and pakistan lost its eastern
half
this made kashmir more important than
ever it became one of the most
militarized places on earth as india and
pakistan deployed planes tanks artillery
and soldiers along the line of control
on the political front in 87 india
reportedly rigged an election
declaring a pro-india party as the
winner now this was a big turning point
for many kashmiris
who felt they were again denied the
chance to vote thousands took to the
streets
in indian controlled kashmir to protest
the occupation
but india met the movement for
independence with harsh resistance
which quickly escalated to more violence
in january security forces opened fire
on demonstrating separatists
turning a two-year-old struggling
movement into a full-blown popular
uprising
more than 650 people have been killed in
clashes between troops and separatists
kashmiri militias like the jammu and
kashmir liberation front
started recruiting muslim youth to fight
for independence
and increasingly attacked the indian
military
pakistan saw an opportunity in this
insurgency
they helped introduce a new kind of
militant group radical islamic fighters
who fought for more pro-pakistan
kashmir by the mid-90s these groups
dominated the insurgency
india responded with incredible military
force deploying 500 000 troops to
kashmir
and they cracked down on militants and
protesters unarmed civilians were killed
and many were forced to flee the
violence
[Music]
and in 98 the stakes were raised yet
again today
india conducted three underground
nuclear tests
pakistan today successfully conducted
five nuclear tests
kashmir became a battleground between
two nuclear armed nations
and another war broke out in 1999
evidence of the attacks being launched
on the indian controlled area of cargill
the past two days have seen some of the
fiercest fighting so far
militant muslim fighters have also
crossed over into some parts
of indian ruled kashmir the 1999 war
ended with another ceasefire but that
didn't stop either country
over the years pakistan's militant
groups got bolder and launched terror
attacks in
and outside of kashmir in 2001
members of lashkar-e-taiba bombed
india's parliament building
in new delhi killing 14 people and in
2008 10 militants from the same group
killed 174 people and wounded 300 in
mumbai
meanwhile indian military cracked down
in kashmir firing bullets and pellets on
unarmed protesters
leaving hundreds wounded and blind
this is the vicious cycle of violence
the indian army's crackdown drives some
kashmiris to join pakistani-backed
militant groups
who carry out violence against the
indian forces
it's a cycle that kashmiri civilians are
stuck in the middle of
just because of this conflict we are
losing our young generations because we
are getting killed every second day we
had a neighbor that two boys were killed
three boys were killed
and there is anger you know among young
generations there are psychological
effects of the conflict okay everybody
is facing some sort of problem in
kashmir hopelessness is everywhere due
to this conflict
when you snatch pens from youth you are
still forcing them to pick up guns
which brings us back to 2019. the
suicide bomber was 19 year old adil
akhmadar
from pawama kashmir according to his
parents in 2016
indian police officers stopped him and
humiliated him by forcing his face into
the ground
the same year he was shot in the leg at
a protest
the next year dar left home with his
brothers to join jaishi mohammed
a pakistani supported militia that
radicalized him and trained him to be a
suicide bomber
a year later he drove explosives into an
indian military convoy
for more than 70 years india and
pakistan have driven a cycle of violence
retaliation and exploitation in kashmir
but beneath it all is the kashmiri's
wish to make a choice
a wish that continues to be suppressed
again and again
by violence best way to
handle the kashmir situation to have is
to have a dialogue
and to hold a referendum and both of the
countries are not doing anything as such
in every action there is equal and
opposite direction the more suppression
you face
the more you rise i just want to get a
freedom to get a
right to do everything as a teenager i
have big dreams
but as a kashmiri the dreams are
surprising here
you